thanks to Babel a language learning app
for sponsoring this episode if you're
interested in growing your language
skills microcosmos viewers get up to 60
off with a 20-day money-back guarantee
when you sign up using our Link in the
description
[Music]
our world today the one that we have
constructed feels as if it runs on
plastic it is a building block in our
bags our bottles clothing toys the list
it goes on and on plastic has become so
prevalent that it is for all intents and
purposes impossible to escape even in
the microcosmos plastic is inevitable it
persists in Long still threads that
could have come from anything maybe it
was shed from a piece of clothing or it
came off of a car part whatever it once
was this shred of microplastic is one of
many pieces just like it turning the
microcosmos into a burial ground for our
waste
but microbes are crafty they're capable
of making lives out of the most unusual
ingredients including plastic so what
does that look like for them and also
for us
well first let's be human about it and
focus on ourselves for a bit and
particularly our love for Plastics we
currently make around 400 million tons
of plastic every year but why
well Plastics covers a wide range of
materials at a chemical level they are
made of structures that repeat over and
over creating a pattern that builds into
a material that is moldable under the
right temperatures and pressures and
nature is full of materials like this
that would end up driving our love of
plastics including natural Rubber and
plant cellulose even wood is a chemical
polymer but nature sets some constraints
on how much we can take and what
precisely is available at the turn of
the 20th century the advances of
chemistry and the demands of War meant
that synthetic plastic was primed to
take over first as part of military
vehicles and parachutes and other
wartime needs and then after in consumer
goods like Tupperware they were cheaper
and lighter than Glass and Metal and so
versatile
but while we've lived with the benefits
of these synthetic plastics for more
than a century now we are also living
with their harms Plastics don't just
surround us in the objects we make they
last in these invisible forms smaller
than five millimeters in length some
might come off our clothes when we watch
them others might be part of our
Cosmetics they can Loft into the air and
come back down with the rain or they can
travel through our waterways ending up
in ponds and oceans James our master of
microscopes found most of the samples
we're looking at today floating in his
Plankton mat while Gathering microbe
samples and on their own these small
fragments of plastic seem so
inconsequential but in a world like ours
where everything is connected nothing is
inconsequential microplastics get eaten
by animals they break down into
chemicals that can be toxic and those
get leached into the environment but the
consequences do not stop there animals
get eaten by other animals which then
get eaten by other animals and so on and
with each step up and around the food
web microplastics and their toxins
accumulate scientists are still working
to understand how microplastics affect
our ecosystems and our bodies but one of
the challenges with microplastics is
just how durable they are those long
chains of atoms once assembled tend to
stay that way
one way to curb the amount of
microplastics that end up in our world
and in US is to stop making as much new
plastic and instead you know recycle
what we've already made unfortunately
only a very small fraction of the
massive amount of plastic we produce
each year gets recycled some of the
challenges are our infrastructure like
figuring out how to sort different types
of plastics so they can be properly
recycled without mixing them up with
each other some of it is technological
finding ways to break down the most
challenging Plastics or developing tools
to ensure each recycled plastic is just
as good as the original and that has led
scientists to turn to the microcosmos
for possible answers with one particular
question in mind can microbes eat
plastic
and there are many ways to investigate
that question and for Maria Pinto a
scientist who has sent us samples before
it's taken her out into the ocean as she
looks to see how bacteria gather on
Plastics
the samples come from all over some are
from the Atlantic Ocean some from the
Pacific some from the Adriatic Sea the
ubiquity of microplastics in her samples
feels similar to the way we find
microbes everywhere but without the
Wonder and awe that microbes Inspire now
microbes are everywhere because they
find a way to endure adapt and spread
their ubiquity is a marker of their
Ingenuity microplastics on the other
hand are a product of our Ingenuity but
also our carelessness with our Creations
it also fits that these two pervasive
entities would find each other Maria has
seen the bacteria gathering on
microplastics their cellular bodies
producing enzymes that might even be
able to break down the Plastics into
their individual units for the bacteria
to use scientists are looking plenty of
other places too Greek beaches mud near
a Japan Japanese plastic recycling
Factory hot springs and Yellowstone
National Park these diverse iterations
of the micro Cosmos and the plastic
eating bacteria in them teach us more
about the enzymes we might be able to
use in the future to recycle plastic
these enzymes come with their own
challenges some work in a narrow
temperature range others are just kind
of slow but the more scientists learn
about how these enzymes work the more
they're able to improve them sometimes
even combining different enzymes to make
one super plastic digesting enzyme
this is all necessary research
urgent against the backdrop of every
other way our planet has been affected
by human behavior we are still only just
beginning to understand how widespread
this Evolution around Plastics is and
how organisms have managed to develop
mechanisms around seemingly unnatural
materials that we've overwhelmed nature
with in 2020 we knew of about 90
microbes capable of digesting plastic
those scientists are still trying to
understand whether all of those microbes
consume the parts we want them to and
more research searching for signs of
plastic digesting enzymes found a
correlation between the abundance of
those enzymes and the extent of plastic
pollution in a given area perhaps if we
understand more about how microbes are
adapting to this pollution we'll
understand better how we can use them
but what does it mean to rely on our
oldest smallest creatures to fix our
newest biggest problems a bacterium can
eat away at plastic but what comes after
what do you think of the scale of what
bacteria have done in the past it seems
possible for them to fix things for us
they've reshaped atmospheres and
constructed ecosystems what's a little
plastic to them but for all bacteria can
do they cannot run our business nor can
they command our infrastructure or curb
our demands bacteria are not going to be
Our Saviors they are simply our
neighbors along with everything else on
Earth
so to make the best use of them requires
more than just understanding how they
work it requires understanding ourselves
and how we work anything else and it may
not matter what we find
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you again to
Babel for sponsoring this episode of
Journey to the micro Cosmos are you
ready to step out of your winter
hibernation and get ready for summer
travel usually trying to learn a new
language requires a lot of time and
commitment making it difficult to
quickly get into conversations well
Babel is a language learning app that
helps you use a new language in real
life situations after only five hours of
practice and it offers lessons in 14
different languages it's the number one
language learning app in the world and
with its short interactive 10-minute
lessons Babel teaches more than just
vocab words it teaches you about the
culture people history and more
associated with the language you are
learning and Babel offers multiple ways
to learn including podcasts Games videos
and live classes so you can choose
whatever format works best for you as a
microcosmos viewer you'll get up to 60
off when you sign up using our link plus
Babel comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee so you can see where a babble
takes you on your language learning
Journey
the people on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons the people who
allow us to continue this exploration of
our Marvelous World with some really
fantastic equipment and a lot of
connections to scientists across the
globe thank you so much for supporting
us on this journey it means a lot if
you'd like to become one of these people
you can go to patreon.com journey to
micro if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss you
can check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]